yes we were wrong
[Music]
at the launch of the note 10 phones like
many tech fans and reviewers we were
more than a bit disappointed not that
much seemingly changed from the s10 in
the SN plus and with the price tag of
$1,100 an O headphone jack all of that
is a hard pill to swallow compared to
the amazing deals that can be found on
the s tense well I got my note m+ and
our initial impression started fading
away and certain aspects of the note
that can't be shown through a keynote
started making themselves apparent along
with a few downsides which I'll talk
about in just a bit I'm gonna keep this
review simple and to the point because I
think choosing to buy a note n will be a
very simple choice for the to user
groups that this phone makes total sense
for the first group is for those who
want the best phone and aren't value
driven in a day and age where there are
a ton of amazing bang for the buck
phones at various price ranges the note
n plus takes a different approach and
that's luxury if there's ever been a
phone to compete with the iPhone 10 s
and fit finish and luxury feel it's the
note 10 Samsung got rid of the extra
logos and text on the back casing and
brought in some impressive color options
the vertical camera arrangement looks
and functions much better since you can
avoid fingerprints while holding it
horizontally and the one-sided button
arrangement with the ultra-thin
contoured frame and hidden earpiece
speaker looks and feels top-notch I love
how the curved display is more minimal
now which in my experience reduced
accidental touches and distracting
reflections that plagues the 1 + 7 I
personally love how boxy this phone is
with smaller curves on the screen
corners and the flat top and bottom even
though I was quite bummed that the
display was at 90 Hertz like the Samsung
made screen and the oneplus 7 pro but if
that 90 Hertz would have meant that this
display wouldn't be as bright and the
HDR video wouldn't be as good as what
the Spohn offers I definitely would
rather have the compromise of this 60
Hertz screen it is gorgeous especially
if you're watching 1440p HDR videos the
speakers are top-notch as well besting
the competition but being slightly worse
than
san likely due to that hidden earpiece
speaker in the US performance is similar
to the s10 but in other countries
Samsung's updated Exynos 9825 provides
slightly better performance and improved
battery life to power those CPUs we have
a massive 4300 milliamp hour battery
which gets about an extra one and a half
hours of screen on time compared to my
iPhone 10s max and if you need to juice
up the note 10 is very impressive
wireless charging is now 15 watts but
what's more impressive is the 25 watt
included charger that can go from empty
to 100% of the huge battery in just over
one hour that's even faster than the
proprietary 30 watt warp charger taking
about an hour and 25 minutes for a
smaller battery this absolutely shames
Apple's $1100 10's max taking three and
a half hours for just 30 174 milliamp
hours or roughly two hours if you spend
more money on the fast charger what
speeds this fast I doubt anybody's gonna
need the optional 45 watt charger which
has charged the phone in about 30
minutes which is crazy before I tell you
about another area that really impressed
me let me give a shout-out to the
sponsor of this video molecule I've been
using this amazing piece of tech for a
few months now and unlike numerous other
filters it actually made a big
difference with my allergies that's
because it's capable of actually
destroying pollutants on a molecular
level not just trapping some of them not
only is the tech inside it amazing but
it also looks fantastic and fits into
your room instead of being an eyesore
it's smart connected
quiet and it's also portable to learn
more about it check out my full review
by following the link in the video
description down below thanks molecule
another area that unexpectedly really
impressed Vadim and I were the cameras
Samsung made a big jump from the note 9
to s 10 and it looks like they haven't
stopped since then in a previous
computer since the S 10 matched up to
the iPhone overall but this time around
it beat it in almost every single test
you have lens choices for panoramas and
portraits and the default beauty mode is
now actually subtle
for video super study is now better and
allows standard lens use and we have
live focus video for the selfie camera
even though we don't have that depth
sensor anymore but it does look pretty
poor on both the front and the rear but
I'm still glad that we have this because
this is a good first step for
computational video blur we have a
dedicated video focusing on this amazing
camera coming out soon so make sure you
guys are subscribed but overall I think
this is the best camera system available
in any smartphone it may not be the best
in every shot or for every use case
because there's a lot of good cameras
out there but overall as a whole this
system is a cut above next I have to
mention Dex it's now also an app that
should be able to link your note to your
PC and allow you to do a bunch of stuff
like texting transferring images and a
lot of other things it's not only
limited to Windows as it seemed at the
launch event but also for Mac's I say
should because no matter how hard I
tried I couldn't get it to work with my
MacBook after hours of testing it out
and just getting constant crashes having
continuity with my iPhone and Mac OS is
one reason why I'm stuck in the
ecosystem but if Samsung gets this right
that will be one less thing holding
Apple users in that ecosystem now on to
the last bit which is the whole point of
the Galaxy Note and that is the s-pen a
major reason why we were wrong in our
initial impressions is that we aren't
huge I spend users like many other
reviewers but judging from the comments
on our video there is definitely a
market out there for this powerful
stylus if you love to have powerful pen
support with a ton of software features
there's really only one major phone on
the market that is the note phones which
automatically makes the note 10 a winner
if we compare the note 10 to the S 10
it's not a massive update but if we look
back to just a year ago to the note 9 it
is impressive how much of a jump Samsung
has made in just a single year yes the
flagship price is hike to $1,100 but
with that price increase
Samson gave us a bunch of extras like
the fast charger in the box a huge
amount of RAM 12 gigs we have 256
gigabytes of faster u FS 3 mem
which is about two to three times faster
than the s10 all of that plus the s-pen
makes the eleven hundred dollar price
tag easier to understand compared to an
$1100 64 gigabyte 10 s max with a five
watt charger now I'm not gonna just sit
here this whole time and praise it and
then not talk about the downsides first
off the ultrasonic fingerprint sensor is
inconsistent unlike the one plus seven
pros it's usable but it's not where I
would like to see it and I was really
hoping that it would get better from the
s10 and it's still just not there
sometimes it works perfectly sometimes
it's a bit slow and sometimes it takes
multiple attempts now along with that
one UI is still behind oxygen OS or pure
Android in terms of speed and fluidity I
noticed at least a few stutters everyday
some animations slowdowns or little
glitches things like that and things
that you don't get with a pixel or
oneplus device so after thinking about
the overall big picture and getting to
actually use this device I have to say
that overall it is phenomenal
good job Samsung please keep pushing the
limits of smartphones and for all of you
guys who are still on the fence
wondering if they should buy a note 10 I
would say go for it I do not think
you're gonna be disappointed thank you
guys for watching this has been max with
max tech if you guys want to see more
videos on the note 10 we have a bunch
that already up you guys can click right
over there and we have more coming that
are very interesting especially our take
on the camera that's included in the
note 10 and why it is the best camera on
the market if you guys want to see more
videos like this one click that little
circle above to subscribe and enable
notifications down below and let us know
your thoughts on the note 10 in the
comment section we want to hear your
guys's opinions this has been max once
again and I will see you in the next
video
[Music]